how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and for
today's news we finally have some
official
spider-man 3 news coming from tom
holland himself today we have some
production news and
some filming news in regards to
spider-man 3. it appears that we know
when spider-man 3 is going to begin
filming
when it's going to finish up filming and
it looks like we know when tom holland
may do
a spider-man 3 press tour which also
points to when we can expect
that first teaser trailer for spider-man
3. we even have
a very short video of tom holland
talking about this himself
so we'll play the clip and break it down
but first if you love superhero content
and want
more of it be sure to subscribe to my
other channel superhero central i'll be
doing videos on marvel
dc star wars dragon ball z anything
super
i'll link it up top and below don't
forget to go over and subscribe
and subscribe to my channel for a chance
to win a dr doom funko
pop so tom holland's dad has a patreon
account and on his patreon account he
posted a video of tom holland
his son talking about his upcoming movie
schedule and here is where he mentions
spider-man 3.
finish uncharted finish spider-man right
in february next year okay two press
stores which should take
maybe together six weeks worth of work
right so he says he has to finish
filming uncharted which we knew was
going to happen we knew he had to start
filming uncharted before he could go
work on spider-man 3. and then after he
finishes uncharted he says he has to
finish spider-man 3.
and then he says that it should be
finished in february
this is actually quite big news because
this means that spider-man
3 filming is going to begin relatively
soon within the next few months
filming was rumored before to begin in
autumn so this means that spider-man 3
is most likely going to start filming in
october or november
and this is great news because that's
only a few months away which means we're
going to start getting
a lot of spider-man 3 information very
soon it also means that we're more than
likely going to get the title for
spider-man 3
a few months from now marvel and sony
have been known to announce the titles
of their films before they begin
filming now obviously spider-man 3 has a
lot of secrecy around it considering the
cliffhanger ending from spider-man far
from home
so they'll wait a while but tom holland
did reveal the title for spider-man far
from home
right at the beginning of filming for
spider-man far from home so the title
should be coming relatively soon
and then tom holland mentions that he
has two press tours
now one of them is definitely for
uncharted and there is a possibility
that the second one could be for
uncharted but it's more than likely
going to be for spider-man 3.
uncharted is going to finish filming
it's going to get a trailer out
and then tom holland is going to go do a
press tour for it and the same thing
is most likely going to happen with
spider-man 3. tom holland will finish
filming the editing process will begin
he'll go do his press tour for
uncharted which should take about three
weeks and then by then some of the
editing will be done for spider-man 3 a
trailer should come out and then he'll
do another press tour for spider-man 3.
which means we could expect the first
teaser trailer for spider-man 3
somewhere around april or may of 2021
and that lines up perfectly with the new
release date for spider-man 3 which is
november
of 2021. that would mean the first
teaser trailer would come out about
seven or six months before the film
shows and that's pretty standard when it
comes to marvel and sony
so finally some good news a lot of
marvel's projects have been delayed but
luckily spider-man 3 is going to film
in germany at first where the
coronavirus is pretty well under control
so spider-man 3 is still set to start
filming
this year and then finish in february of
next year
and then hopefully not too long after
that we'll get the official teaser
trailer
for it i want you to let me know in the
comments down below what you think the
title of spider-man 3 is going to be
and remember it has to have the word
home in it let me know what you think in
the comments down below don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to stay up
to date on
everything relating to the mcu as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof